page engagement belloubet beaucoup de
prudence dire nous n'avons pas de leçons
à recevoir de l'exécutif sur le bon
fonctionnement du parlement séparation
des pouvoirs elle devrait en être la
garante et je la renvoie puisqu'elle
nous dit mais finalement les sénateurs
toutes sensibilités politiques font de
je dirais de l'instrumentalisation je
lui dirai mais chère madame vous avez vu
comment a fonctionné la commission à la
semaine nationale avec votre majorité
elle a écrasé la sphère ben alla cette
commission et imaginez vous un parlement
avec une seule chambre avec la majorité
dans marche aujourd'hui la sphère
benalla n'existerait plus eh bien nous
faisons encore une fois notre travail
le bicamérisme montre toute sa force en
la matière